hey how's it going bros my name is peter
pan I'm here playing butt sniffing pugs
I was supposed to play this with March
sex we played it last time but she's in
Italy right now might might see how did
you get here know you're here yeah
[Music]
yes I was about to say it I love it it
looks very nice my said we're filming a
video right now UK I was just about to
ask you - yeah are you ready - yet every
time you have to do your hair every time
should I change
No as you change this is the peep ideal
C by the way which will be at with this
game is pretty cool yes you can alright
I'm good yeah please
you know they're gonna be monetize that
videos so I'm Edgar now we sniff each
others butts to change our powers you
okay do you need some support do you
want to wear this helping okay so we
have to bark at the Beacon hey the Ducks
game no don't pee on the Ducks mites it
was wrong with me
my scent would never do that okay no I
don't know lik there's a oh the axolotl
up there you can barely see it do you
see it you catch that it's a nice
roasted I'm Barney the medium please
there you go what happened Stefan uh
2012 references yeah don't peel Stefano
not okay okay you're a bad boyfriend
I know might say you're not paying
attention
[Music]
oh my god yes I'm sorry yeah that's the
door oh my god that's so cute
yeah I'll poop here how do you know him
I don't know we have to figure that out
[Music]
okay let's catch him mattifies you hate
butterflies right I know don't worry God
wine
you caught a ladybug do I like ladybugs
yay No
okay again finally you're doing
something useful for the thing okay
sorry I'm sorry
hi I'm bad boyfriend I'm sorry your
shitty girlfriend no I didn't stop
showing your nibs please okay thank you
what are you doing what are you doing
right now
I
okay I'm getting you butterfly money
what are you doing I can show you my
back
my set please can you stop touching
yours I would be naked if I don't poo my
visa you had a deal that you would do
that later you want me to take it off
not now we're filming no just even touch
go away go away nice my sin never heard
you burp before I know I really love
that I can play games with my girlfriend
and this is really one of those games
that you can really enjoy it with your
partner just walk around sniff each
other oh my god you did so well Maya
[Music]
thank you so much for playing with me
today we do a little kiss wait I'm not
ready just for the thumbnail okay I need
to look good for you I'm ready I am of
you
[Music]
okay are you [ __ ] gay come on
keep your eyes open look at me when you
kiss me
[Music]
thank you so much watching [ __ ] thank
you my tears so much yeah I'm glad I can
again I wasn't expecting this we're
gonna play every single time we get a
little closer to a real kiss I think we
leave a like for reviews for [ __ ] sake
can you shut up and let me do the damn
back and look pretty
thanks for watching leave a like if you
enjoyed I'm going to wash my face and
brofist that's not what it's not
[Music]
[Music]
you